expensive spins right back to the
baseline goes right to the rack there's
dead man right there Blake Griffin this
is a fall away his break said a fall
away follow it appreciate it but hope
that I let this bowl hailing still
strapped a guy his side and then into
the three-point shot at 610
as you mentioned earlier Oh 42 for Blake
Griffin whoa
Sean as I sew I sewed and get his man
going one way and go away from him
baseline and draw some mob but merchants
sending him left so he takes left and
finishes with the reverse work and you
see the physicality that both guys bring
to the matchup excellent up fake up and
under folks
spinning and winning with the left hand
Jordan clinging to him in vain in pain
now as he fouls out of the game it's not
Reggie Jackson
that's a whoosh the basketball with that
much speed for money into the other he
did it all right there Wow look at Isaac
trying to stay with Blake look at him he
gets punctured in the chest with this
look at that right here the shoulder
right into the chest on an and-one
opportunity
what's this tight little space he gets
through with Andre running a little bit
of interference little post up
old-school style
left hand and watch the finish here goes
with that strong shore and the spin move
down to 42 seconds to play in the first
Blake Griffin coming right at you there
Blake is going to hand this thing over
to Reggie Bullock who's gonna cut hard
and he's gonna make Yogi's to have to
come to him and now Yogi's she's gonna
have to go over to Blake or he's gonna
dunk it and when he does the smart play
the last play the last piece of this
thing you lob it up - Andre - Detroit
watch this pump fakes so Wilson buys it
totally overpaid for it in fact Willie
cauley-stein - picks up another five
I think they called it on Shumpert